مسؤول كبير في حماس قال لشبكة CNN إن
مصر وقطر والأمم المتحدة
يتواصلان الآن مع المجموعة
بشأن جهود الوساطة ، وقال نفس
المسؤول
إنه علم من الوسطاء أن
إسرائيل أعطت الانطباع
بأنها غير مهتمة بوقف
إطلاق النار.  وزارة
الخارجية يا سيدي ،
ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عن
جهود الوساطة هذه في هذه المرحلة ،
يمكنني أن أخبرك أننا لا نعتقد أن هذا
هو الوقت المناسب لوقف إطلاق النار ،
ولا يزال هذا هو الوقت
الذي نتحدث فيه عن حماس.
مئات الصواريخ على مدينة
بئر السبع في
جنوب إسرائيل وهذا هو الوقت
الذي يجب أن تدافع فيه إسرائيل عن نفسها
وتهاجم
البنية التحتية للإرهاب في حماس ، هذا
إذا أوقفنا إطلاق النار الآن سوف
تكسب حماس هذا هم أو هم  سنصل إلى
هدفه وهدفه بضرب إسرائيل وعدم
دفع الثمن
الذي لدينا ، سنهاجم
البنية التحتية لحماس في غزة وسنصل
إلى النقطة التي سيقول حماس إنها
تفهم أن  إن شن هذا النوع من
الإرهاب على المدنيين الإسرائيليين
ليس خيارًا بالنسبة له في المستقبل ،
لذلك بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
يشعرون بالقلق من أن هذا قد يتحول
إلى حرب شاملة ، فأنت تقول ما
هو تقييمك إذا كانت إسرائيل غير
مهتمة  وقف إطلاق النار إلى أي مدى تسوء الأمور يا سيدي ،
لا أعتقد أنه من الواضح جدًا
أن نقول إننا نريد
الدخول في وقف إطلاق النار مرة واحدة عندما
لا يزال شعبنا
في الملاجئ أو في الغرف الآمنة في
الملايين من الإسرائيليين تقريبًا
يمضون وقتهم في
في الملاجئ في ذلك الوقت ، يجب على حماس أن
تأخذ
في الاعتبار أن هذه ليست طريقة
لإسرائيل أن تنهي هذا
الصراع الذي بدأوا فيه هجومًا إرهابيًا على
إسرائيل ، وهي تمارس حقها
في الدفاع
عن سكانها والمواطنين الإسرائيليين
للأسف ، هذا ليس
صراعًا كنا نرغب في الدخول فيه إلى
إسرائيل ، لقد
فعلنا الكثير من أجل منع التوتر ، وفي
كل من القدس
وفي أماكن أخرى في
يهودا والسامرة.
عدم السماح
لليهود بدخول جبل الهيكل في يوم القدس
في اليوم الذي نحتفل فيه
بإعادة
توحيد مدينة القدس وقررنا
أه إرجاء
جلسة استماع المحكمة بخصوص جيرارد التشيكي من
أجل عدم الحصول على
مزيد من الاهتمام بشأن هذه القضية القانونية
أيضًا
وحتى
الاحتفال بهذا اليوم المقدسي تم إلغاؤه
خلال ذلك اليوم من أجل منع
التوتر
وكل خطوة صحيحة تم
الرد عليها بمزيد من العنف
والإرهاب ومؤخراً من
خلال هجومهم على قطاع غزة
دعني أضع هذا